find the slope of the line that goes
through the ordered pairs 4 comma 2 and
negative 3 comma 16. so just as a
reminder slope
slope is defined as rise over run or you
could view that rise is just change in y
and run is just change in x the
triangle's here that's the delta symbol
it literally means change in or another
way and you might see this formula and
it tends to be really complicated but
just remember it's just these two things
over here sometimes slope will be
specified with the variable m and
they'll say that m is the same thing and
this is really the same thing as
changing y they'll write y y2 minus y1
over
x2 minus x1 and this notation tends to
be kind of complicated but all this
means is is you take the y value of your
endpoint and subtract from the y value
of your starting point that'll
essentially give you your change in y
and it says start to take the x value of
your endpoint and subtract from that the
x value of your starting point and
that'll give you change in x so whatever
which whatever these work for you let's
actually figure out the slope of the
line that goes through these two points
so let we're starting at and actually we
could do it both ways we could start at
this point and go to that point and
calculate the slope or we could start at
calculate the slopes let's do it both
ways so let's say that this our starting
point
our starting point is
the point four comma two and let's say
that our endpoint
our endpoint is
negative 3
comma 16. so what is the change in x
over here what is the change in x in
this scenario so we're going from 4 to
negative 3. if something goes from 4 to
negative 3 what was its change well it
takes you have to go negative you have
to go down four to get to zero and then
you have to go down another three to get
to negative three so our change in x
here our change in x here is negative
seven actually let me write it even let
me write it this way let me write it
this way our change in x
is equal to negative 3 minus 4 which is
equal to
negative 7. if i'm going from 4 to
negative 3 i went down by seven our
change in x is negative seven let's do
the same thing for the change in y and
notice i implicitly use this formula
over here our change in x our change in
x was this value our end point our end
of x x value minus our starting x value
let's do the same thing for our change
in y
our change in y
if we're starting at 2 and we go to 16
that we that means we moved up 14 or
another way you could say it you could
take your ending y value and subtract
from that your starting y value and you
get 14. so what is the slope over here
well the slope is just change in y over
change in x
so the slope over here is change in y
over change in x
which is our change in y is 14 and our
change in x is negative 7 and then if we
want to simplify this 14 divided by
negative 7 is negative
is negative 2. now what i want to show
you is is that we could have done it the
other way around we could have made this
the starting point and this the endpoint
and what we would have gotten is the
negative values of each of these but
then they would have canceled out and we
would still get negative 2. let's try it
out
so let's say that our start point was
negative 3 comma 16 and let's say that
our endpoint
is the 4 comma 2. 4 comma 2. so in this
situation what is our change in x
our change in x if i start at negative 3
and i go to 4 that means i went up 7. or
if you want to just calculate that you
would do 4 minus negative 3
4 minus negative 3 but needless to say
we just went up 7. and what is our
change in y
our change in y over here or we could
say our rise if we start at 16 and we
end at 2 that means we went down 14.
or you could just say 2 minus 16 is
negative 14. we went down by 14. this
was our run so if you say rise
over run which is the same thing as
change in y over change in x our rise is
negative 14
and our run here is 7. so notice these
are just the negatives of these values
from when we swap them so once again
this is equal to negative two and let's
just visualize this let me do a quick
and let me just do a quick graph here
just to show you what a downward slope
would look like
so let me draw our two points
so this is my x-axis
that is my y-axis so this point over
here four comma two so let me graph it
so we're gonna go all the way up to
sixteen so let me save some space here
so we have one two three four it's four
comma
2. so 4 comma 2 is right over here 4
comma 2. then we have the point negative
3 comma 16. so let me draw that over
here so we have negative 1 2 3 and we
have to go up 16. so this is 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
so it goes right over here so this is
negative 3 comma 16
negative 3 comma 16. so the line that
goes between them is going to look
something like this
try my best
my best to draw
a relatively straight line that line
will keep going
so the line will keep going so that's my
best attempt and now notice it's
downward sloping as you increase in x
value the line goes down it's it's going
from the top left to the bottom right as
x gets bigger y gets smaller that's what
a downward sloping line looks like and
just to visualize our change in x's and
our change in y's that we dealt with
here
when we started at four and we ended at
or when we started at four comma two and
ended at negative three comma sixteen
that was analogous to starting here and
ending over there and we said our change
in x our change in x was negative seven
we had to move back our run we had to
move in the left direction by seven
that's why it was negative seven and
then we had to move in the y direction
we had to move the y direction positive
14. so that's why our rise was positive
so it's 14 over negative 7 or negative
2. when we did the other way we started
at this point
we started at this point and then ended
at this point started at negative 3 16
and ended at that point so in that
situation our run
our run was positive 7 and now we have
to go down in the y direction since we
switched the starting and the end point
and now we have to go down negative 14.
our run is now positive 7 and our rise
is now negative 14. either way we got
the same slope